ahora que estamos más familiarizados con
la idea de frecuencia al el icam
partamos de ella y desarrollamos el
principio déjame ponerlo aquí el
principio
sitio y esta vez vamos a ver el
hardy hardy vainberg
baa
a ver
y este principio nos va a ayudar a
conocer cómo será la frecuencia alérgica
de una población o bien conocer qué
porcentaje de la población será un
motivo está recesiva am como sigo está
dominante o heterocigotos para un gen y
esto se basa en lo que ya vimos el tema
de frecuencia alélica pero antes de que
sigamos en todo esto vamos a hacer
algunas suposiciones las cuales nos
llevarán a tener una población con una
frecuencia alélica estable de generación
a generación así que vamos a suponer en
primer lugar déjame ponerlo aquí vamos a
suponer que no hay selección natural
ay
selección selección natural o ya sea
artificial
inclusive artificial entonces no hay
selección natural ni artificial ya que
ésta cambiaría mi frecuencia alélica y
justo es lo que no queremos es decir no
sucederá que las personas con uno de los
alelos o con el otro tendrán mayor o
menor probabilidad de reproducirse y de
tener una descendencia viable también
vamos a suponer que no habrá mutaciones
así que déjame ponerlo
ciones eso quiere decir que ninguno de
estos alelos cambiará de una generación
a otra o que dará lugar a una nueva
característica por ejemplo ojos verdes o
cualquier otro color otra cosa que vamos
a suponer es que la población va a ser
bastante grande déjame ponerlo aquí una
población
acción grande
grande
y esto es muy importante por lo tanto
descartamos la idea de lo que vimos en
el vídeo pasado el cual hice solo para
entender el concepto de frecuencias
alélicas y recuerda en este vídeo
dijimos que uno de los cuatro alelos de
la población o un cuarto de los alelos
de la población era el alelo dominante
el alelo café mientras que tres cuartos
o el 75% son el alelo azul el alelo
recesivo vamos a suponer mejor que
tenemos población grande poblaciones muy
grandes muy muy grandes y esto es porque
si tenemos poblaciones muy pequeñas
puedes imaginarte que dependiendo en
cómo se reproducen es muy fácil tener
cambios en las frecuencias pero en
poblaciones muy grandes podemos hacer la
suposición de que tenemos frecuencias
alérgicas estables y de nuevo
hablo de estas tres suposiciones porque
son las que me van a ayudar a tener
frecuencias alélicas estables déjame
ponerlo aquí esto me ayuda a tener
cuencias frecuencias alérgicas
y las estables
es lo cual es muy importante como ya
vimos si tomamos la frecuencia del alelo
dominante que se puede denotar con la
letra p minúscula y le sumamos déjame
ponerlo aquí a p le sumamos la
frecuencia del alelo recesivo que lo
pusimos con con minúscula así que déjame
ponerlo por aquí como minúscula si
hacemos la suma de estos dos bueno
cuánto será el resultado en este caso
podemos ver que la suma es un 100% y
siempre será este resultado o bueno 1
porque estamos suponiendo que sólo hay 2
alelos en la población entonces tienes
el 100% de probabilidad de tener al
menos uno de estos dos cualquiera que
sea la frecuencia aquí o dicho de otra
manera 100% menos éste me daría este de
aquí entonces la suma de estas dos
letras será el 100% o
o
y ya con esto podemos empezar a hacer un
poco de matemáticas interesantes lo que
nos permite pensar en cosas como
homocigotos y heterocigotos y bueno para
poder hablar de eso lo que voy a hacer
es tomar esta expresión y elevar a ambos
miembros al cuadrado esto lo voy a
elevar al cuadrado y esto también lo voy
a elevar al cuadrado y llegamos a un
poco de álgebra en la clase de biología
cuando elevamos esto al cuadrado del
lado izquierdo de la igualdad que nos va
a quedar bueno solo estamos elevando un
binomio al cuadrado perfecto y tal vez
quería repasar un poco esto si sientas
que te estoy hablando el chino hay
muchos vídeos de álgebra en lacan
academy que hablan de este tema así que
vamos a hacerlo
el binomio al cuadrado será am bueno voy
a empezar con p cuadrada p cuadrada ya
esto habrá que sumarle bueno recuerda
dos veces el primero por el segundo así
que lo voy a poner así dos veces el
primero que es
por un por
y que es mi otra letra porque más el
cuadrado del segundo es decir q cuadrada
y por supuesto 1 al cuadrado es
exactamente lo mismo que bueno uno
entonces me va a quedar esta ecuación
que tengo aquí y ahora te pregunto qué
significa cada uno de los términos de
esta ecuación bueno pensemos en lo
siguiente p cuadrada es lo mismo que
déjame ponerlo así esto es lo mismo que
pe por p estás de acuerdo
p por p y que era p que representa p
bueno pues ven está justo aquí es la
frecuencia del alelo dominante recuerdas
es el porcentaje del alelo en la
población que es dominante puedes decir
que la frecuencia del alelo que es
dominante se multiplica por ella misma o
bueno otra manera de pensar a p es
hablar de probabilidad p es la
probabilidad de que si de una manera
aleatoria escoges uno de estos cuatro
alelos aquí tengo uno
4 si de una manera aleatoria escoges uno
de estos cuatro alelos y recuerda que es
bueno en este caso estoy usando mis
hombres simplificada población tenemos
que suponer una población muy grande
pero bueno pensando en el ejemplo de
aquí una manera de ver a pep es
preguntarse cuál es la probabilidad de
escoger un alelo aleatoriamente que sea
un alelo dominante o cuál es la
probabilidad de que el alelo que
escogiste sea una ley lo que hace eso es
una manera de ver a p
es más déjame ponerlo aquí en representa
lo voy a poner por aquí
la probabilidad la pro ba
le da
de obtener un alelo dominante d
tn
a ver en mayúscula un alelo café
entonces que es por p bueno
p por p lo puedes ver déjame ponerlo así
esto lo puedes ver como la probabilidad
de obtener primero un alelo dominante y
después otro alelo dominante es decir la
probabilidad de obtener dos veces el
alelo dominante p mayúscula esa es una
manera de verlo pero también hay otra
forma de pensar lo sería tomarnos la
probabilidad de que una persona en la
población sea un cigoto dominante es la
probabilidad de que alguien obtenga d
mayúscula y d mayúscula bastante
importante porque siguiendo la misma
lógica entonces cuánto va a ser q
cuadrada bueno siguiendo la misma lógica
o cuadrada es lo mismo que q que
multiplica aquí y si pensamos en lo
mismo
estamos hablando de tomar la
probabilidad
la probabilidad de obtener un homo
cigoto recesivo es decir b minúscula b
minúscula dicho de otra manera la
probabilidad de obtener dos alelos
recesivos uno de tu madre y otro de tu
padre y entonces éste representa la
probabilidad de que si tú nacieras de
una manera aleatoria en esta población
grande tengas dos al de los recesivos
ahora que significará dos veces p por q
bueno este término aquí en medio lo
podemos ver como primero pensemos en que
representa p
por q p por q es la probabilidad de que
tomando uno de tus padres sea cual sea
obtengas un alelo dominante del primero
y un alelo dominante del primero y del
segundo obtengas un alelo recesivo
por un p de alguno de tus padres y el
otro de tus padres o bien no puedes ver
al revés es lo mismo que pensar en la
probabilidad de que tomando uno de tus
padres sea cual sea primero desde un
alelo recesivo y el otro desde un alelo
dominante y si sumamos estos dos me va a
dar justo dos veces
por q solo estamos cambiando el orden de
los términos
si sumas p por q mas q por pm es dos
veces pay por q asi que que representa
esto bueno dos veces puede por q es la
probabilidad no voy a poner aquí la
probabilidad de ser heterocigotos es
decir que uno de tus padres sea cual sea
te de un gen dominante y el otro te dé
un gen recesivo
un gen recesivo y este es un resultado
muy claro y que a mí me gusta mucho este
resultado que tenemos aquí porque sólo
con hacer tres suposiciones bastante
claras y utilizando el concepto de
frecuencia alélica fuimos capaces de
obtener esta expresión que tengo aquí
que de hecho tiene una idea muy poderosa
acerca de la frecuencia alélica y de la
frecuencia genotípica de una población y
como puedes ver todo esto tiene sentido
porque todos ellos suman uno la
probabilidad de que alguien sea un
músico dominante más la probabilidad de
que alguien sea heterocigotos más la
probabilidad de que alguien sea un
cigoto recesivo dará un 100% porque
cualquiera de las personas de esta
población va a caer en uno de estos tres
casos en fin yo te dejaré en este vídeo
pero en el siguiente vamos a usar este
principio o esta ecuación de hardy
vancouver para obtener resultados muy
interesantes acerca de las poblaciones